well the violence in Jerusalem's Old
City ruptured on Sunday when Israeli
police entered the Alex komoroske
they've been tipped off that armed
police palestinian youths had barricaded
themselves in and were planning to
attack jews visiting the temple mount's
during the jewish new year earlier we
spoke to Dan iseman Jerusalem affairs
reporter for The Jerusalem Post and I'll
submit there had been any political
fallout for Benjamin Netanyahu's
government it depends on how you
calibrate fallout in terms of the
Palestinian Authority you I would say
that yes there has been as well as a
from Hamas and the Jordanian King they
have uniformly condemned any changes to
visitation rights for any Muslim on the
Temple Mount with some members of Hamas
saying that it's it's comparable to
starting a holy war the neighborhood
where the stoning happen is in a
neighborhood called R Mon huh not sieve
which is directly adjacent to an Arab
village the the driver
Alexander lepovitz was struck while
while driving home from Russia tion on
Sunday night on a road that basically
separates the two neighborhoods and
although there have been no arrests it's
believed by police that it was in fact a
rock attack the residents the Jewish
residents of of the area were the attack
took place expressed frustration and
fear they believe that these attacks are
basically being carried out with
relative immunity because most of the
perpetrators are minors which restricts
the government from prosecuting them
altima what happens is the offenders who
are arrested in these cases let's say
people under 18 are released to the
custody of their parents which has not
proved to be a effective deterrent to
say the least
so Benjamin Netanyahu held an emergency
meeting cabinet meeting last night
saying that he is ordering that the
punitive measures against rock throwers
of any age is radically heightened so he
is discussing applying mentor prison
sentences as well as very prohibited
fines however it's it's still going to
take a fair amount of time for any of
that to be turn into legislation and you
know enacted